nathan fillion almost wasn't cast as
malcolm reynolds how could the series
actually come back each episode costs
how much stay tuned to find out the
untold truth of the short-lived classic
series firefly
firefly is a science fiction show
concerning the space set adventures of a
band of rogues but it just as much keeps
alive the tropes of westerns according
to joss whedon the biography of amy
pascal the nugget of what would become
firefly came to creator joss whedon
during a vacation to london to read on
the trip he brought along the 1974
pulitzer prize winning the killer angels
a historical novel about the hard
scrabble lives of soldiers fighting in
the civil wars battle of gettysburg in
1863.
as a part of a deal with the fox network
he had to submit a new show soon and the
book inspired him whedon said about the
show i wanted to play with that classic
notion of the frontier not the people
who made history but the people history
stepped on but whedon also wanted to
make a show set in space offering quote
gritty realism that wasn't an alien
rip-off and which didn't look like so
many other lesser-made-for-tv sci-fi
projects whedon mashed all that together
and it became firefly the final touch
coming when he expanded the character
list from just a handful to a full cast
of nine just like in john ford's classic
1939 western stagecoach which followed
seven strangers as they traversed the
american frontier
after supporting roles in saving private
ryan and blast from the past a big part
of the 90s abc sitcom two guys a girl
and a pizza place nathan fillion became
a pop culture icon because of his time
on firefly he's so intertwined with the
role of captain mal reynolds for so many
people that it's something of a surprise
that the part was written with another
actor in mind at a 2014 comic con
nicholas brendan best known as xander on
buffy the vampire slayer said that his
boss creator joss whedon approached him
in his trailer and offered him the role
of a spacecraft captain in the new show
he was writing whedon planned on
starting the show after buffy wrapped
production in 2003 but then fox wanted
the show six months earlier than
originally planned meaning brendan
couldn't do firefly because his old job
remained ongoing according to joss
whedon's biography neil patrick harris
auditioned for the role of simon tam and
rebecca gehart shot scenes as companion
inara before leaving the series and
being replaced by morena baccarin
while it would eventually be hailed as
one of the best shows of the 2000s and
ranked among tv's all-time greatest
science fiction works firefly was
phenomenally unpopular when it debuted
on fox's prime time schedule in the fall
of 2002. it was officially listed as the
125th most watched show out of 156 shows
in the 2002-2003
season although fox didn't do the series
any favors of 14 produced episodes only
11 aired and when they did broadcast
they were presented out of order firefly
aired on fox on friday nights in a time
slot where shows often died from neglect
and it's clear that the network didn't
know what to make of the show or how to
market it according to insider
executives thought the show was too dark
but also wanted more gun play and
lamented that no romance was possible
between captain mal reynolds and crew
member zoe washburn on account of how
the latter was married to pilot wash
what if we just told mal we need a
couple a day instead of asking him
he's the captain wash right i'm just the
husband
it seems as if the few viewers firefly
actually attracted during its ill-fated
original run on fox in 2002 became
devoted fans of the show who dedicated
themselves to making sure the series
continued on accurately predicting that
the show probably wasn't going to stick
around for long without some kind of
intervention viewers connected via
message boards email forwards and the
fan site immediate assistance to save
firefly before it was even officially
canceled between october and december
2002 firefly fans mailed thousands of
postcards both to fox and the show's
sponsors to thank them for airing a show
of such merit and quality but fox
couldn't be swayed from its decision to
discontinue firefly in late 2002
undeterred creator joss whedon shocked
the show around but no other channel had
any interest in scooping up firefly
three years later robust dvd box set
sales in the range of 500 000 convinced
universal pitchers to spend 40 million
dollars on a firefly sequel movie
serenity hit theaters in fall 2005. we
can't dive in this you know why because
we are so
very
pretty
we are just too pretty for god to let us
die
with such an open-ended concept firefly
could have generated dozens of episodes
over many years unfortunately it was
cancelled halfway through its first and
only season leaving many potential and
pitched episodes left permanently on the
what if pile during a cast panel at
2012's new york comic con cast member
nathan fillion remembered co-star alan
tudyk's voluminous and detailed episode
ideas explaining he had a great one
where there were some criminals who
engage in illegal dogfights and there
was a planet where one side of the
planet was perpetual knight they had
these big feral dogs there dead or alive
would have been the 15th episode of
firefly and its script was completely
written but ultimately unused except for
some parts pushed into the episode the
message it involves a factory bombing
near where the serenity crew attends a
fair and the suspect is an old friend of
mal and zoe a future episode also would
have explained inara's syringe that
makes an enigmatic appearance in the
first episode of firefly according to
writer and producer tim meniere in the
2012 tv special brown coats unite it was
a magic syringe that upon injection
killed instantly anyone that assaulted
inara the companion was set to endure a
kidnapping that would end in the deaths
of her assailants a gang of reavers
tv shows cost a lot of money to make
particularly ones set in the future
where the action takes place primarily
on a spaceship and on a new planet each
episode firefly was thus an expensive
series with each episode racking up
about 2 million dollars in production
costs according to slashdot but even
with that high of a budget the show's
crew still had to find ways to scrimp
save and scale back in order to make the
show they wanted to make
for example according to recycled movie
costumes enemy alliance soldiers on
firefly wore the same armored uniforms
used in starship troopers and on an
episode of power rangers and as firefly
is at its heart of western the show
finds captain mal reynolds on various
planets riding a horse according to
fillion on twitter the production used
the same horse every time michael k
johnson writes in who do cowboys and
bronze buckaroos that firefly reused
props from another fox revisionist
western and two of the guns used were
leftovers from the early 90s show the
adventures of briscoe county junior
firefly is named after its central
setting a firefly class spaceship named
serenity a lot of thought and effort
went into making sure it was the perfect
ship for the series and the characters
who inhabited it production designer
carrie meyer told mtv news about his
discussions with joss whedon regarding
the ship saying he wanted each of those
spaces to have a distinct identity so
that you always knew where you were no
matter where you were in the ship after
the show ended production during the
2002-2003 season it was all disassembled
rather quickly with meyer saying it's
very difficult to hold on to that sort
of thing he went on to say that the wood
used for the ship's set was recycled
into his next gig as production manager
on the short-lived cbs drama vegas
about six years after the demise of
firefly nathan fillion found his next
big project with abc's castle portraying
the title character a mystery novelist
who helps the nypd solve crimes as
research while castle would run for
eight seasons and make fillion very
famous firefly was never far from his
heart as he told entertainment weekly in
2011 it was my favorite job ever what
wasn't great about it nor were
phillian's firefly co-stars out of his
life forever a full half of billion
shipmates popped up on castle over the
course of its run further castle is
loaded with references big and small to
fillion's previous series for example in
the 2009 halloween episode vampire
weekend castle tries on his costume a
long brown coat much like the one he
wore as captain mal what exactly are you
supposed to be
space cowboy
okay a there are no cows in space b
didn't you wear that like five years ago
a moment where castle takes down an
assailant with a single gunshot mirrors
a similar sequence and firefly when jane
shoots an armed attacker in the leg
while aiming for the attacker's head
which castle also admits to
in the safe alliance-controlled central
planets or core worlds in the firefly
universe reavers are akin to the
boogeyman those that hang around in less
friendly environments know that they're
real dangerous and terrifying reavers
are cannibalistic pirates brutalizing
their victims in any number of ways
before stealing their cargo rarely
leaving survivors they're a recurring
menace in the soul season of firefly and
the spin-off serenity movie at a panel
at wondercon 2005 joss whedon explained
that he came up with the reavers as a
parallel to the perceived villains of
old western movies and fiction saying
every story needs a monster in the
stories of the old west it was the
apaches in western movies white settlers
were usually the so-called good guys and
the apache were demonized as the de
facto bad guys whedon didn't want the
rivalry to have anything to do with race
however preferring to imply that the
reavers became the way they are because
anyone who goes out into space and goes
mad can become a monster
in march 2011 firefly received some new
attention when the science channel
acquired rebroadcast rights to the
sci-fi series and began airing reruns of
all 14 episodes in an interview relating
to that news and asked by entertainment
weekly if he'd returned to firefly
filian replied in the affirmative saying
if i got 300 million dollars from the
california lottery the first thing i
would do is buy the rights to firefly
make it on my own and distribute it on
the internet legions of firefly fans
took philly at his word and teamed up to
actually acquire the rights to the show
and hand them over in the hopes that
production of new episodes could begin
the website
helpnathanbyfirefly.com was established
and about 70 000 fans pledged to donate
money to the cause this project
ultimately didn't pan out rights holder
20th century fox just wasn't looking to
sell no matter the price
the popularity of firefly has only grown
since its cancellation in 2002 and there
just might be a market for a revival of
the series at the 2020 television
critics association press tour fox's
president of entertainment michael
thorne floated the idea telling the rap
the macro answer is anytime we look at
one of our classic titles if there's any
way to reinvent it for today so it's as
resonant now as the original was and is
to the fans were wide open he added that
a few years prior during the reboot
craze that brought the likes of twin
peaks roseanne and the x-files back to
tv a firefly continuation was considered
but he also revealed but we had the
orville on the air and it didn't make
sense for us to have as a broadcast
network who was very targeted to have
two space franchises on our air firefly
executive producer tim munir further
mentioned that he and creator joss
whedon discussed a reboot saying we have
talked about different permutations and
how that might work i would love to see
like an 8 or 10 episode limited
adventure in that universe check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite sci-fi classic series are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]